Welcome to the lesson on cross-validation.
You've been doing validation all along in this class,
so this won't be brand new for you.
But in this lesson,
we'll actually go into some more detail, some more comprehensive algorithms that
can help you validate your machine learning in a better way.
Remember back to earlier in this class, I gave you an example of
a machine learning algorithm that actually sells me clothes.
And that was not a made up example.
There's a startup in San Fransisco that does that.
But you can imagine that if you're the person who's in charge of writing that
machine learning algorithm, you don't want to find out if I'm
going to like a shirt by just mailing it to me.
You want to have some way of assessing whether your algorithm is,
is actually doing what you want it to do, of testing it, of validating it.
So that's what we're going to be talking about in this lesson.
I'll see you in the classroom.